a cover of Health magazine and it's the
first unretouched cover in the
magazine's history hard because
everything nowadays is so filtered it's
every touch was it hard and scary
especially six months after having a
baby it was so scary and leading up I
was still breastfeeding when I did this
shoe and I was just freaking out the
whole time my heart was probably good
because they're real full I know but you
know I'm retouched is actually really
hard for everybody on set I noticed like
you know the makeup artist the
hairstylist everyone's like oh my god
what we gonna do with her bruise on her
knee like who's gonna cover it the
makeups not covering everything's very
stressful and doing it in natural
lighting adds that very real element as
well boy a natural lighting is not my
friend
but I like a nice amber dim light no but
it was really important for me to do
this because you know we were on
Instagram all the time we see people
photoshopping everything you're like
when does it end and you know when
you're scrolling on Instagram you
constantly compare yourself to these
other people and for me I wanted us like
take a step back and show a real moment
of someone who actually is six months
postpartum is not being photoshopped and
be that real person and real influence
we have four kids and two of them were
teenagers once almost teenager and
literally it's so hard on social media
because everybody compares mean if you
don't get enough like yeah I cancel
something out it's like everything has
to be validated in social media and
everything is filtered so I think it's
really cool that you're such a super
model so all these girls look up to you
especially like it's really cool that
you're brave and okay to do it and why
are we comparing our bodies postpartum
to all these photoshopped when we should
be admiring our bodies that we even
created life
[Applause]
like give ourselves a little bit more
time to bounce back we don't need to do
it you know two months I'm in the middle
of things I know but even before the
Health magazine cover though people
always used to say that you're too curvy
which I'm like I wish I was Kate Upton
the super-crook supermodel like is that
nuts to you when it was first happening
obviously it was really hard because I
was like I work out all the time why is
everyone calling me fat and now the
conversation has completely changed and
people are like what what when did
people say that and that just shows how
the industry is changing how our voice
matters and things can change we mean
something because of this cover yes you
know because of this cover I actually
started a hashtag hashtag share strong
just on Instagram to create a community
where we could all share our real selves
or what continues to motivate us to
continue being strong yeah and a lot of
people are posting you know no makeup
selfies or their stories and it's so
great to go on that hashtag and get
inspiration from all these other women
because we're so strong and to be able
to share in each other's strength is
what makes women so amazing
yeah absolutely and if people don't
realize if you even if you're willing to
never a kid like there's so much going
on if you have a baby like not only your
body is just giving up but your
emotional state it's kind of crazy so
like somebody talking to someone that's
just had a baby in a photo shoot saying
oh you need to lose weight that will
send you in a spiral ya know the
hormones are crazy and no one talks
about it the hormones after pregnancy
for me were crazier than when I was
pregnant and it took forever for them to
calm down like months after
breastfeeding I might still be more
model here's my best but this is my best
so I was I freaked out cuz I was pumping
so I was working this thing which is the
worst pumping is the worst work it's so
painful I don't care what anyone says
anyway but somebody had kind of tossed
out and it was only a tiny bit of breast
milk left in the bottle no I lost my
ever-living Micah
crazy person went in my closet and just
blew like collapsed on the floor was
crying so I was like you have no idea I
work for that yes and really there was
like nothing in the bottle I'm crazy but
it literally it's just a hormonal period
I don't think people take that into
account especially when we're women in
the public eye like it is a hard time
and our energy is literally being sucked
out of us so you don't feel like
yourself you don't literally it out of
you it is so difficult and something
people need to talk about more a guy a
hundred percent I talk about it any
chance I can yeah I complain about
pregnancy without any chance like it is
beautiful and I love my children you
love it yes but here's my thing your
share as strong is your daughter right
so how is she yours Tara Strong I love
that well you know I want to be the
example she can look up to and I want to
create a happy healthy world for her to
grow up in yeah of course we actually
have a mom here today who was inspired
by Kate say hello to Alex beautiful the
red lip with the red skirt I'm into it
so what do you want to say to Kate I'm
Alex I'm a new mom and I just want to
say thank you when I was pregnant I was
a little over a mean before I was
pregnant was a little over a hundred
pounds and I'm ashamed to admit it but I
was so afraid to gain weight and what I
would look like and then I got pregnant
and I found out I was having a baby girl
and I knew that if I wanted her to love
herself that it had to start with me I
loved being pregnant I love the big
belly but then towards the end I started
getting that was nervous feelings again
like what am I going to look like will I
still be strong what will people think
and I had her and I loved my body but
then I saw you on the cover of health
and unretouched and it was so inspiring
it made me realize like I don't owe
anybody pretty or perfect or skin
should be an example for my daughter and
to just be someone she can look up to
and be strong for my daughter it's like
the best thing that I could be and you
don't know how many people you've
touched so just thank you so much yeah
we're all on our own journeys it's so
important to Sarah thank you so much so
many women like especially in the field
that you're in that you touch like that
but you know it means so much to me
because you know when you hear all the
criticism sometimes you're like why am i
doing this and stories like that I
realize this is exactly what I am doing
this and we're all in it together and
we're all experiencing it together so
thank you so much for sharing well I
think you're so beautiful coming out yes
aesthetically you're beautiful but you
have a certain confidence about you and
I love I think confidence is so sexy
it's the sexiest thing on a man or a
woman I've got just be happy be
confident and it'll exude it yeah and
but we all go through our ups and downs
we don't all feel confident all the time
but it's working it's getting back to
that confident place that's so important
in that journey there yes I love you I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this